what has happened to salman rushdie is
um
i think shocking to every thinking
person and another level it's something
which has a history leading up to it of
33 years
salman rushdie was attacked this week
prior my understanding is to giving a
talk
in new york
and he was gravely injured i believe he
is expected to survive but uh
might lose an eye and uh has serious
damage which will
impact him uh
from here on through his life
um this is
presumably the result
of a fatwa issued
33 years ago by ayatollah khomeini
based on the fact that he had apparently
delivered a offense to allah
in the satanic verses a book of fiction
that he he penned and he has lived under
that threat courageously for all of
those decades and uh i learned in
looking into that fatwa that apparently
there is a monetary reward
offered it was increased in in 2012
several million dollars
that has been offered for a person who
eliminates him it was never lifted and
uh several of the translators of his
work into other languages were attacked
and um i believe a couple of them were
killed
so you know even even translating the
work is deemed worthy of um
it's deemed a mortal offense yes and
although
the iranian government has distanced
itself from the fatwa the monetary
reward uh was raised by a semi-official
entity connected so this is really a
fundamental question about how the world
is to be run
what is within the purview of a
nation-state and
what is not
it is also well worth noting as many
people have
that there is some comparison to be made
between
this
violent act and cancel culture and of
course one comparison that could be made
is that cancel culture in which you are
simply stigmatized and ostracized and
maybe driven from your chosen profession
is certainly preferable to being
attacked by a knife-wielding madman
but
there is a way in which this is a
difference in degree but not in kind
these are both
instances
in which people are preferring a system
in which what may be said and what may
not be said is dictated by some
authority and that
those limits should
guide discourse and be severely punished
when they are
violated
and
there is an alternative of course which
is the alternative upon which the west
is based in which individuals are free
to think and to say
essentially anything now of course there
are limits worth talking about but in
the realm of ideas in the realm
of narratives should you be free to
express anything and
be challenged if what you have said
is uh
vile or dangerous but not be silenced
and of course this is in one way
counter-intuitive because
everyone who believes that certain
things are right in whatever way things
can be right and other things are wrong
would of course prefer a world of
uh the rightness flourishing and the
wrongness uh
being
absent but the problem is as the
american founders correctly realize the
truth is counterintuitive that even
though most ideas that are expressed are
probably at best valueless and very
frequently wrong and sometimes downright
dangerous the most dangerous thing is an
environment in which you cannot express
ideas that are not sanctioned because
that is a world in which there can be no
progress now there's a world frozen in
some state
it's it's the frozen-ness really which
uh
which i think is what many people who
uh think that free speech
should go by the wayside
are are not recognizing it is it is also
the height of hubris
it is an arrogance that comes of
imagining that now finally after however
long it is that you want to keep track
of in the past finally we have arrived
in a moment of perfect understanding
and whereas we can all look back on
previous moments and say oh weren't they
confused weren't they small-minded
weren't they ignorant didn't they not
know the things that we know now it
imagines that we are now
omnipotent and omniscient
and that we have full possession of not
just the knowledge but also the power
and therefore that we want the full
possession of the power to make sure
that everyone who doesn't yet see things
as clearly as we do
can be forced to be relegated to um to
basically be our underlings
so i wanted to try to put this in
context of a model that long time
listeners of dark horse will have
interacted with many times in many
different contexts
in the comparison between
fatwa culture and cancel culture you
could view them as uh distinct and one
preferable over the other
or you could view them as the same thing
in a different form but the purpose is
to make sure that what is accepted is
accepted by fiat rather than by some
process in which we all participate
and um
here's the thing that i think needs to
be explored
one of these
is obviously religious
right it is by religious authority that
the fatwa on salman rushdie was issued
and the other
of these is nominally secular yes
that is the wrong way to think about it
though it is true at a factual level but
it is untrue at a deeper level
and what i would argue is that we come
all of us irrespective of what lineages
we emerge from we all come from a world
of religious authority every lineage has
that feature up until some point at the
least and some of them continue to
happen
those religious authorities
are
the result
of an evolutionary process
and
what i've argued many times and i'm
going to argue here again
is that you cannot found a religion in
the same way that you cannot write a
myth
you can write a narrative and then
selection can act upon narratives
throwing about throwing out almost all
of them relatively quickly after they
are written preserving a few that have
some kind of value and then honing them
and turning them into durable myths yes
and the same thing can be said
of a religion you cannot found a
religion
you can found something that functions
on those modalities which i would say is
correctly understood to be a cult and
then a very tiny fraction
of those cults turns out to have some
sort of durability lasting power
and uh capacity to in some way or other
enhance
the lives of uh believers and adherents
yeah and you know cult
always has a negative valence to a
negative connotation but
um if we try to put that aside for them
what you're arguing is that a story with
staying power can become myth a cult
with staying power can become religion
but at its uh and its origin neither a
story nor a cult has the capacity to at
once at its inception call itself either
myth or religion right
i apologize um so what i'm what i'm
getting at i agree with the point about
the negative valence i think we need to
stop you having a negative valence
for uh
cults and stories and we need to think
about them in terms of the chances that
that one is a durable one are very very
low so our skepticism of both things
right a story can be entertaining but
what are the chances that a story is
valuable well if we know nothing about
the content of the story it's very low
and um the same thing for a cult what is
the chance that that set of beliefs and
traditions has
is more beneficial than it is harmful to
adherents chances are very very low but
you know all all the religions of the
world that have succeeded in uh
protecting a population and
facilitating its flourishing have
started there and all the myths have
started as just stories as well
so yeah i do
i think we need different words though
because cult does also mean something
you know
different and specific and there are
plenty of stories that don't have the
capacity to turn to myth so it's i would
say this is an imprecise mapping it well
i don't think so but i think it does
require uh extra precision to get there
because somebody who imbues
a
cult with the capacity to advise that
person as if it were a religion that has
withstood the test of time
is making an error so the point is that
the negative
i didn't follow that the negative
connotation of the term cult comes from
the fact you wouldn't you wouldn't say
that a a book that contained a
description of a potential a candidate
religion was itself dangerous it is the
adherence to it
that is to say people who ascribe it
uh with that kind of
potential
that kind of value in the present before
it has stood the test of time and before
it has been refined by selection in any
way are making an error they are
um
treating something with the capacity to
advise that it doesn't it is not yet
known to have
that that's fair i don't think that
addresses the question of how i mean i
just i wasn't i'm not prepared for this
conversation i'm not remembering the
various technical definitions that have
been proposed for what makes a thing a
cult as opposed to some other small
organization and
i think that there are
qual characteristics of cults that are
not inherently found in religion well so
what i what i the part that's important
for the argument
that i'm making is that
the value of these things has never been
in their factual accuracy
right and this has tripped up
secularists who look at the factual
inaccuracy of many of these belief
systems and imagine it to invalidate the
whole project
rather than saying actually factual
accuracy was never the point
what the point is prescriptive
how should you behave
right and because these traditions the
ones that have withstood the test of
time i'm not arguing that any individual
one is good or bad
right there may be some that are pure
bad
probably all of them have components of
both
um but the
point is
when you know as as i've argued many
times a literally false metaphorically
true idea is one that if you behave as
if it was true you do better than you
would if you behaved according to the
fact that it is false and so
in this framework you have the ability
to hand down ideas ideas that may be
factually in conflict with the evidence
have people behave as if it is not in
conflict with the evidence and for some
reason do better now what i'm arguing is
that cancel culture
is doing exactly this
cancel culture
wokeness is strangely indifferent to the
fact that what it claims is factually
true is so deeply in conflict with what
is well understood already and sim and
and observable by simple means simple
means right and so this i think again
this is trippy
uh we who are highly skeptical of the
woke revolution
are in some ways tripped up the way
scientific secularists are tripped up by
religious claims that are obviously not
right like the earth is six thousand
years old right
secularists are often
you know well obviously it's not six
thousand years old years old therefore
it is invalid oh so the tripped up by
you by tripped up you mean
we find the obvious falsehood
and we say that's all you need that's
all you need to know like we're done
here clearly this makes no sense these
people aren't serious they're not paying
attention to reality therefore can we
just stop already right and that's not
that's that's neither
um
it has been often discussed that that is
actually not the right way to dissuade
people who who believe a thing with you
know with with rationality and logic in
the face of a firmly held belief but i
think you're saying you're coming at it
from a slightly different perspective
you're saying uh this is going to be
that this is
ineffective in understanding what it is
because we're stopping too soon in our
analysis of it right we are we are
we're like people who want to drag a
geologist to a creationist and say
talk show the strata right show them the
strata show just how long lived the
thing is and then they'll understand
that that thing they believe in is wrong
and the point is factual accuracy about
the nature of the dirt was never the
point right where the universe came from
was never the point where people came
from was never the point the point was
always how should you behave right now
the dangerous thing here and the thing i
want to distinguish right obviously
you know if i have to pick between uh
you know fatwas and stabbings and uh
being maligned on wikipedia obviously i
prefer the latter right however
the one the ancient version is at least
about something now again i'm not
defending anything about it it's
absolutely vile that somebody uh
stabbed solomon russia you're trying to
explain it the same way you have tried
to explain the nazis
well yes but i'm also saying there is
something the fact that cancel culture
has some analogy in the sense that it
wants to fiat belief that it wants to
fiat beliefs that are in conflict with
factual evidence and is completely
indifferent to the comparison between
the two yeah is about the fact that this
is some sort of brand new cult right it
has two things going against it one of
them is
uh it wants perfectly dangerous insane
things
and
it is in no way tested by any process
right
so
the point is it's like somebody came up
with this [ __ ] and now wants to hand
it down with the authority of god and
the point is the authority of god is not
about a deity the authority of god is
about the test of time and no time has
passed here right so what we're watching
is
a
cult of some kind of power structure
some kind of power structure that wants
the right to alter the most fundamental
things about civilization on the basis
of beliefs that are completely wrong but
it hasn't even demonstrated that it
knows anything that would allow it to
last a decade right nothing at all
[Music]